okay baby we're doing this we're going
Carla up operation silent Vanguard with
one of our soldiers with it before they
deploy cannon [ __ ] burns rookie
can I add this can I get sniper rifle
[ __ ] height okay hold on back up
Kevlar armor
okay back up hold on hold on
what the [ __ ] okay hot
she's a squatty he's a sharpshooter
right and he was a [ __ ] sharpshooter
what is this thing so I always [ __ ]
get back
gremlin okay
Canadian air Ranger shoes the Ranger
Mike Kennedy how do I get the
Sharpshooter okay okay [ __ ] it let's
just do it
let's just do it okay we're just going
to do it like just commit to a life as
usual
I love actors thank you is ready to
deploy on your order commit yes Deb
wretches apparently the resistance has
been relying on an old data tap along
the advent network that had up until
this point been eluding the aliens
detection yeah recent Intel suggests the
data the resistance found is critical to
the aliens latest operation yeah
unfortunately Advent is already moving
to take out the device and we can't let
that happen
eliminate all hostile contacts and
secure the area
protect that device at all costs you bet
it BAM bang head way you got hostile
forces why the dark' to dump installed
nearby darkness we need to lock down the
area and secure the device at all costs
solid copy
there we go spotted got a great eye
thing
a trap behind plastic
that's right behind that tray we all
love trays oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that
just [ __ ] walk right through that
[ __ ] and I guess they had a car well I
should always like focus on her that's
how good I got what's up [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
I guess we're just going right [ __ ]
in anybody dad objective here minus-15
we've got a line on the target move to
protect that gear at all costs
correct five of the [ __ ] enemy [ __ ]
you doing okay [ __ ]
all right sadly this [ __ ]
he is going yet moving out all right
Chuck I'm a disgusting really
okay get at I can't get this right here
okay let's do it again Joe come on Ali
let's do it dear [ __ ] oh [ __ ] just it
looks like bubble gum
so you gonna fire now oh yes
holy [ __ ] you see a [ __ ] sharpshooter
that's great what they done holy [ __ ]
this is going to be [ __ ] up now okay
you go here and I want you to pop this
[ __ ] pop up [ __ ] there we go
yep yep that [ __ ] right the [ __ ] hat
all right the [ __ ] hat
are you [ __ ] serious bro
okay well this [ __ ] obviously has to
get this guy right here okay adding one
percent don't [ __ ] this up this bad she
better better get here soon huh yeah
right there I also need you to take out
this bench oh [ __ ]
sure ice is gonna be fried Oh what's he
doing now I'll do it okay
yes stupid [ __ ]
yes stupid [ __ ]
okay what's going on now Oh Fred what
that guy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
have fun good mother my control
see doing uh heroes them for the dead
wait are you going now
I hope the other guys can do it come on
come on
thank ya now holy [ __ ] that you should
probably kill this guy II really don't
really have much choice just eliminate
this bench 48 percent [ __ ] it oh [ __ ]
she should use the sword she's done
she's done
okay this bench
can I throw fraggin a look I just
[ __ ] get them and kills guy right we
are so [ __ ] our dick is our dick and
stuff she gonna shoot at me oh no like I
say is that kind of gets what yes very
sad I have to say I was very sad
oh what the get out of your bird tell
you little [ __ ] [ __ ] don't attack the
Machine [ __ ]
so [ __ ] searches do Oh brought her back
yeah kill her how do I like on my
controller not great it's [ __ ]
disgusting the [ __ ] going on here okay
okay come on calm down
where is that alien blob we're just
[ __ ] where'd he go
- okay so I get Skyy back yeah okay okay
bench you want to get your dick sucked
prepare to get sucked [ __ ] this [ __ ]
right here that's right I'm talking
mafia-style twitch all you want this
[ __ ] I want this [ __ ] right [ __ ]
here and I want you to pop this [ __ ]
pop up yeah interesting interesting she
can attack that machine more oh there it
is
[ __ ] disappeared for a while that
you'll [ __ ]
finally oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] gross but okay
oh no no Samantha sit duck
okay this [ __ ] here this picture five
your something nice where's the [ __ ]
animate right there you will right here
and then I'll even care if you [ __ ]
well throw a grenade just do it judge
just that okay
oh shut gun strike right there and then
pop this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
boom
just get this [ __ ] back okay
he's like I'll fetch
okay all right so enough oh great it's
inside him now
[ __ ] [ __ ] gonna hit me or something
oh did you just tell him you [ __ ]
killed him
[Music]
is there a way to restart this one then
there's a light one way and that's
forward [ __ ] can I just hmm
pocket
get it together my weapons spent now
[ __ ] Wow he's [ __ ] mess as you shoot me
this wristwatch how much of that there
we go
[ __ ] miss that tail in better a
stairs greater from my [ __ ] dead
friends coming it right walking the
flames I had just a drink
okay well this [ __ ] [ __ ] it we're doing
this hard reload let's kill this [ __ ]
[Music]
target eliminated oh great
hello friend reloading
that's a [ __ ]
oh great okay let's waste these wastoid
that's affirmative right there now [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
34% get get up little [ __ ]
show fail to connect yeah no [ __ ] okay
you see Emma's copper I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah you see let's cover it let's
kill this wastoid wait shake kill him
yeah [ __ ] kill this [ __ ] real quick
yeah alright la we gotta do now
[ __ ] my time right yeah [ __ ] get
right there I think of a [ __ ] get
[ __ ] right there yeah you want to
kiss him for what
yeah good chance right here
just get him you like that critical hey
Matt - I'll bet hey you're running huh
no no head I back out head out back out
you got right there [ __ ] we're going to
pop this [ __ ] right here [ __ ] say
enemy destroyed I'm out of firepower of
its confirmed all hostiles are down in
the area is secure status confirmed
mission accomplished
mission accomplished such got something
good here yeah [ __ ] that one up huh yes
thanks for watching guys